Would you work with us in terms of what regulations
you think are necessary in your industry?
Absolutely.
Mark Zuckerberg is the multi-billionaire founder
and CEO of Facebook,
and this week he testified before Congress,
assuring lawmakers that his company will play
nice with government regulators.
Ladies and gentlemen, Richard Hendricks!
Richard Hendricks from HBO’s Silicon Valley
is the bumbling CEO of the unfortunately named
Pied Piper.
His memorable moments include evacuating his
bowels, vomiting,
and then lunging into a glass wall in front of all of his workers.
One is poised when being grilled congress,
the other can’t even deliver a pep talk
to his staff without hurling under his desk.
But our best hope for the future of the internet
is with Richard Hendricks and not Mark Zuckerberg,
and here’s why.
We need to take a more proactive role and
a broader view of our responsibility.
It's not enough to just build tools, we need
to make sure that they're used for good.
In his testimony, Zuckerberg welcomed regulation,
and even agreed to help craft it.
Mark Zuckerberg is in the same position as
the late-nineteenth century railroad tycoons.
Contrary to conventional wisdom, these robber
barons embraced regulation
as a way to raise the barriers to entry for
competitors
who were eating into their profits and market
share.
Still sporting a hoodie, Richard Hendricks
is at an earlier stage of his career.
He’s trying to build a new internet in an
effort to outmaneuver Hooli,
a fictional amalgamation of Google and Facebook.
Hooli is the future...
Even Richard’s specific approach to disrupting
Facebook is more than just TV fantasy.
We could build a completely decentralized
version of our current internet.
With no firewalls, no tolls, no government
regulation, no spying.
Information would be totally free in every
sense of the word.
Richard represents the next wave of innovation—
the competitor who, if congress and the government stays out of it,
will eventually erode Facebook’s market
share by offering a better product.
When you add more rules that companies need
to follow
that's something that a larger company like
ours inherently just has the resources to go do
and that might just be harder for a smaller
company getting started to be able to comply with.
There’s a real world movement in the tech
world to build a new decentralized web
that would give users actual control over
their own data,
and create open platforms that aren’t controlled
by any single all-powerful CEO.
One reason to bet on these real life projects
to decentralize the internet,
projects like Blockstack and Ethereum,
is that talented engineers are beating down
their doors,
because working at Google and Facebook is
lucrative but it's also soul killing.
We've been given the opportunity to rewrite
the most important thing in human history
and we can build it the way it should have
been all along,
you know, not this shitty addictive parasite
that companies like Hooli use to spy on us
exploit us.
As Facebook and Congress start to write new
rules for cyberspace,
all of us who believe in free expression and
permission-less innovation
have a real stake in making sure that the
future of the internet
remains as wide open and uncharted as possible.